ukrainian forces are continuing to hold
their capital from the russians but
there is word tonight the city is
surrounded associated press reporter joe
fetterman has been in kiev since the
fighting began and joins us now joe
thanks for joining us once again it's uh
it seems very quiet and key of right at
this moment but things seem to change
at any moment the situation can change
there what's going on now
yes i'm in the heart of kiev central uh
central part of the city near the main
square and it is not only quiet it is
eerily quiet i mean it is so quiet that
a neighboring building uh has wind
chimes that i can hear tingling and
jingling uh when there's a breeze here
in the heart of a normally a very busy
street
so nobody is out on the streets right
now we're under curfew and anybody who
goes out is considered a suspect and
risks being shot so
that said the quiet does not always last
we're in a lull we've seen many of these
lulls and they usually they may last an
hour or two but they're frequently
interrupted by air raid sirens last
night there was gunfire behind us so the
heavy fighting has not reached the heart
of kiev but it's certainly on the
outskirts of town and the fears are that
it's getting closer and closer and in
fact what we're hearing from the mayor
of kiev he's told the associated press
that the city is encircled uh what is
that doing to the the mood of people in
kiev the the threat of russians getting
closer and the concern about supply
shortages in the days to come if the
situation doesn't change
yeah the mayor gave us a mixed message
on one hand spirits remain high i think
people are encouraged by uh the leader
the president zelinski uh standing up
for his people remaining defiant i think
they're encouraged by signs that the
ukrainian military is performing well
and inflicting heavy damage on the
invading russian forces but at the same
time he says the city is surrounded he
says it's too dangerous for people uh to
leave right now and he's worried he says
things are hanging on for the time being
but he's worried about food supplies
he's worried about medicine and he's
worried about the city eventually being
strangled by the russian forces
now joe talks are scheduled for tomorrow
between the two sides
what's the reaction from people in cube
to that news is it optimism or is it
skepticism
i would say it is cautious optimism at
best people have been through a lot the
there's a lot of mistrust toward the
russians and president putin has been
very unpredictable throughout this whole
thing so there are a lot of question
marks surrounding uh these talks
starting with what are russia's motives
are they serious about these talks or is
this something just uh just to buy time
we don't even know when these talks are
going to begin we don't know what the
agenda is going to be is it going to be
just a short-term ceasefire or is it
more substantial talks talking about the
issues that led us to this point who's
going to represent the sides are they
going to be senior decision makers or
just low-level diplomats so there's a
lot of uncertainty a lot of question
marks here that said anytime you get the
two sides together any time that they're
talking to each other that gives you at
least something to latch onto
for hoping to resolve this crisis
we'll see if anything comes of those
talks all right thanks for joining us
once again associated press reporter joe
fetterman in kiev